the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon and a song of ice and fire
update video well my friends it looks
like we have another new update from our
old friend george r martin over on his
not a blog website in this new update he
reveals that he has now seen nearly
every episode of house of the dragon he
also reveals some new information about
the winds of winter as a matter of fact
he finally lets us know exactly what he
has been writing
if you have been following all of his
other updates on his website then you
would know that he doesn't do this very
often let's go have a look at it now so
you can see exactly what he's been up to
lately as you can see he once again
released a lot of information on his
website now most of this doesn't have
anything to do with game of thrones
house of the dragon or the winds of
winter the new updates we are looking
for are down a little further he said
house of the dragon i'm glad you asked
i've now seen rough cuts of 9 of the 10
episodes and i continue to be impressed
i cannot speak to the special effects
many of which are not done yet but the
look of it is great and the acting the
directing and the writing are first rate
and yes for all you book fans it is my
story
sure there are some differences from
fire and blood we could not show you
three different versions of every major
event and not keep our sanity but i
think ryan condell and his writers made
good decisions they even made some
improvements hear say i know but being
the author i am allowed to say so for
many years as some of you may recall i
have been saying the tv version of shae
was a deeper richer and more nuanced
character than the shea in my novels in
a similar vein i am vastly impressed by
the show's version of king viserys who
is played by patty considine who gave
the character a tragic majesty that my
book viserys never quite achieved i want
to say kudos to patty ryan and his
writers and miguel and the other
directors there are a lot of great
performances in house of the dragon or
hot d as i hear some are calling it you
may never have heard of some of our
actors but i think you will learn to
love them just as you did with the cast
of game of thrones now this sounds like
some very great news not only has he
seen basically every episode but the
author himself is saying everything
looks great and not only the acting and
directing but the writing as well now we
never know how things will unfold in the
future but as of right now george r
martin is on record saying how so the
dragon's first season is his story that
is very exciting he actually even said
something i just said so myself in my
last video
fire and blood is very different from
his other novels and a song of ice and
fire given the fact that there are three
different versions of nearly every major
event during the dance of the dragons
now because of this ryan and the other
writers will have to decide on which
version they will want to focus on and
according to the author he said ryan and
house of the dragon's other writers did
make some good decisions and even in
some areas they made some upgrades to
what was written in fire and blood i
also agree with what he said at the very
end of the update now i'll be the first
to say i'm not very familiar with a lot
of the actors we will see in house of
the dragon i have only seen a few of
them in some other things but i went
into game of thrones the same way there
were only a few of the actors from game
of thrones who i was familiar with
already but i ended up falling in love
with nearly every single one of them
now if you're a fan of hbo and all of
their other shows then you already know
they are the best at finding amazing
actors for their stories as a matter of
fact this is one thing that i was never
worried about because i've always been a
fan of their casting and most of their
other shows i've said it before and i
will say it again i think hbo will learn
from some of their mistakes made on game
of thrones i also think house of the
dragon showrunners ryan condell and
miguel sapochnick are well aware of what
was said about game of thrones writers
and showrunners david and dan i can't
imagine they will want to follow in
their footsteps by making some of the
same mistakes which is why i think ryan
has made sure george rr martin gave him
the green light on every draft or
outline he has written for the show
so unless they're lying to us for some
reason we should expect to see his story
in the show i mean he did say so himself
after all now let's see what he said
about the winds of winter it says when's
you say yes still working i finally
finished a clutch of cersei chapters
that were giving me the fits now i am
wrestling with jaime and brienne the
work continues though not as fast as
many of you would like now this might
not seem like much of an update but this
is actually more than he has given us in
a very long time it's not very often he
reveals exactly what he has been writing
now that he says he is done writing all
of these cersei chapters that were
giving him fits hopefully that means the
next chapters will be written a lot
faster on the other hand you never like
hearing that he still has several more
characters chapters to go
now it is exciting to know that he is
working on jaime and brienne i don't
know about all of you but the whole
jaime berean and lady stoneheart
storyline is one of the ones that i'm
looking forward to reading the most the
fact that he is even revealing he is
writing jaime and berean chapters tells
me that he hasn't gotten there yet
i don't think he would want us to know
which if any of them survived that
ordeal as you all know he doesn't like
giving anything away so that's why i'm
assuming he's still leading up to that
moment i'm very interested in seeing
what happens when brienne gets jaime
back to lady stoneheart now if this is
in fact the case then that most likely
means he still has a lot more writing to
do before he gets the wins of winter
finished then again i am only guessing
the fact of the matter is no one knows
exactly how much he has done except for
him unfortunately the only thing we all
know for sure is that it's still not
here let me know what all of you think
about these new updates now i know some
of you think we will never see the winds
of winter but i'm on the other side of
that fence at least for now like i have
said before i go back and forth on this
myself some days i think it will be here
soon then on other days i think we will
never see it at all
thankfully we have house of the dragon
for now that's where my main focus will
be for the foreseeable future now that
we're only about 3 months away from the
first episode you will be seeing a hell
of a lot more videos from me if you have
any video ideas regarding house of the
dragon leave them down below i'm always
open for suggestions
also don't forget to subscribe if you
want to be entered into the giveaway for
the copy of fire and blood the winner of
that giveaway will be announced on july
1st
this is a book of imaginary history
chronicling the targaryen kings of
westeros it provides a context and a
background for everything that happens
in a in a song of ice and fire and it's
uh not actually written by me it's
written by archmaester gildane of the
citadel of old town who's a a very
distinguished scholar but also a
somewhat idiosyncratic and crotchety old
man who has strong opinions on the
historical figures he's writing about so
uh some of his uh views may creep into
the text i don't
vouch for its authenticity
the targaryens were people
they were good ones there were bad ones
some of them were mad they were all the
product of uh
generations of incest you get uh people
of extraordinary ability and
extraordinary physical beauty which is a
targaryen hallmark they had certain
physical attributes like purple eyes and
silver gold hair that was much prized
and
was considered you know more beautiful
than the run of normal men but you also
get mad men or people who are troubled
in one way or another they were not gods
they were they were people but they were
people with a very particular heritage
as always i want to thank all of you for
watching this video i hope everyone has
a great day i'll see you soon
bye
[Music]
you